i'm
alive
ordinaire
monde bolt un son puissant des paroles
en anglais est une particularité sur les
quatre musiciens deux sur frères show
départ de de la chanson et puis après
forcément comme je dis j'y donne aux
bébés et on la range tous ensemble
chacun apporte sa touche personnelle
jérôme a des idées de
de mélodies de son de guitare etc et
après on vient coller une histoire
dessus ça dépend des fois c'est celle
inverse et toujours des embrouilles
fraternelle j'ai envie de dire mais
non il ya une
sur scène notamment des choses comme ça
une authenticité qui du fait qu'on se
connaît vraiment très bien qu'on est
frais
des fois on n'a pas besoin de se parler
pour dire les feux
le groupe in volter tibi noie dans sa
forme actuelle il existe depuis mars
2010 une influence très blues rock il ya
un côté un peu années 70 en et musique
si je dois donner une couleur on va dire
récente actuelle groupe américain et
nelson qui serait un peu dans cette
couleur 70
bon voilà avec une couleur un peu ac/dc
goven méoule un autre groupe américain
le groupe travaille sur son deuxième
album dans un studio d hôtes c'est nous
les avons rencontrés ce journal à leurs
côtés paul deslauriers guitariste
arrangeur directeur artistique c'est la
touche supplémentaire lui qui a
travaillé avec céline dion
c'est très rock cette erreur que moscou
comme aux jeux des années soixante dix
sur blues rock les influences de deux
guitaristes de blues etc on parle de
déco comme d'être à plein de la cdc y
est décrit comme ça mais où est-ce que
c'est cru à la fois c'est une énergie
rock and alors ok là qui est vrai et
puis en même temps c'est l'esthétique
musicale de la chose les chansons
surtout je mangeais trouvé qu'ils
avaient des bonnes chansons on m'a
envoyé des maquettes puis ça c'est cool
c'est bon j'ai un petit j'écouterai ce à
quoi ils travaillent très fort avec boss
leurs chansons une basterds instrument
est très très fort mais sont convaincus
de larges depuis 6h en porcelaine ça
travaille ça travaille leur deuxième
album devrait être dans les bacs fin
septembre une résidence est prévue à la
rentrée à l' usine à chapeaux avant
bouillon